Transcription: Ilayda BILDIK
Relecteur: eric vautier
Combien de petits détails
vous énervent, vous agacent,
vous tourmentent chaque jour ?
Comme, oublier ses clés,
oublier d’éteindre la lumière la journée,
perdre son téléphone ?
Et si vous pouviez
en faire quelque chose ?
Bonjour, je m’appelle Lilia, j’ai 17 ans.
Il y a quatre ans,
j’étais une collégienne lambda.
Un jour, j’ai décidé
de participer à Science Factor,
un concours de sciences, par curiosité.
Pour y participer, il fallait présenter
une innovation de notre invention
qui devait contribuer aux aspects
écologiques et sociaux de notre monde.
En m’y penchant un peu plus,
je me suis intéressée à l’aspect
écologique du concours.
Puis j’ai essayé de lister les problèmes
majeurs liés à l’environnement.
Le thème du gaspillage étant
vaste et revenant souvent,
j’ai décidé de me documenter
un peu plus à ce sujet.
Et c’est comme ça que j’ai pris conscience
de la quantité de chaleur de l’eau
que nous n’exploitons pas chaque jour.
Après de nombreuses autres recherches,
j’ai été surprise
de ne voir que de rares innovations
proposant de régler ce problème.
En faisant des calculs,
j’ai appris qu’on pouvait chauffer
une chambre pendant 2,7 heures.
2,7 heures.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Tout ça grâce à la chaleur
de l’eau usée d’une douche.
C’est ainsi qu’au fil des mois,
j’ai monté mon projet Ecological Heating,
chauffage écologique,
ça sonnait mieux en anglais,
qui m’a amenée à être
lauréate du concours.
Il s’agit tout simplement d’un système
qui vous permet de récupérer
la chaleur de l’eau usée de votre douche
pour chauffer une pièce de votre logement.
Le fonctionnement est simple :
vous prenez votre douche
comme à votre habitude.
L’eau sale, mais encore chaude,
s’écoule de votre bac de douche
dans une cuve.
Dans cette cuve,
j’ai ajouté des serpentins en cuivre
reliés au radiateur de la pièce
bénéficiant de l’installation,
entre autres,
une chambre de votre logement.
Dans les serpentins en cuivre
et le radiateur qui forme un circuit fermé
circule de l’eau propre.
Quand vous prenez votre douche,
l’eau sale mais encore chaude présente
dans la cuve chauffe les serpentins,
donc l’eau se trouvant à l’intérieur.
Cette eau va chauffer
le radiateur et donc la chambre.
Je l’ai dit tout à l’heure,
j’étais une collégienne lambda.
Mes seules connaissances et compétences
étaient celles apprises
en classe ou lors d’activités
faites en parallèle.
Si on y pense bien, on a tous
les moyens d’entreprendre nos projets.
On n’a pas les mêmes méthodes,
mais c’est cette différence
qui est importante et qui nous permet
d’avancer plus vite et mieux.
Pour mon projet,
j’ai mis en place un procédé
qu’on peut qualifier de scientifique,
que l’on apprend et applique à l’école.
D’abord, on se trouve face à un problème.
Pour moi, le gaspillage de la chaleur
de l’eau de la douche.
Ensuite, on émet des hypothèses,
on réfléchit à des moyens
de résoudre ce problème.
Puis, on teste ces hypothèses
et on approfondit
celles qui restent envisageables,
et ce jusqu’à une résolution du problème.
Je dis une résolution du problème,
car on sait tous
qu’une problématique peut être
résolue de différentes façons.
Notre diversité nous permet
de penser différemment
et c’est grâce à elle
que nous pouvons avancer.
J’ai pris l’exemple
de la méthode scientifique
qu’on utilise plus souvent
vous ne le pensez, d’ailleurs.
Si votre grille-pain tombe en panne
et que vous êtes bricoleur,
vous êtes d’abord face à un problème.
Vous émettez des hypothèses
sur la provenance de la panne,
vous la trouvez et finissez
par réparer votre grille-pain.
Ainsi, vous pourrez à nouveau
déguster vos tartines
qui vous tiennent à cœur, chaque matin.
Il existe plein d'autres méthodes.
On en maîtrise au moins une.
Il faut juste s’en rendre compte.
C’est le tremplin pour les idées
que vous aviez en tête depuis longtemps,
mais que vous ne voyiez pas
encore comment les entreprendre.
Au début, on a peur des obstacles,
on se dit que ça sera long,
que ça sera dur, que ce sera coûteux.
Mais quand on y pense, quand on tente,
on arrivera toujours plus loin
que si on ne fait rien.
Et puis on rigolera de ces obstacles
lorsqu’on les aura surpassés.
Par exemple, pour participer au concours,
j’avais réalisé un prototype.
Lors d’une soirée test, j’ai créé
une petite inondation dans ma chambre.
Comment vous dire que
ni mon bureau, ni mon parquet,
ni moi-même étions ravis
de ce qui venait de se passer.
Mais grâce à ce petit contretemps,
j’ai pu avancer
dans la conception de mon projet.
Est-ce que ce ne serait pas
grâce aux obstacles
que nous pouvons avancer ?
Je me rappelle le moment
où je devais modifier
mon programme informatique
alors que je n’y connaissais rien.
C’est grâce à Internet
que j’ai appris les bases.
Aujourd’hui, on a accès
à plein de ressources
comme Internet,
les Fab Labs, les Repair Cafés.
Alors pourquoi ne pas en bénéficier ?
Comme quoi, même si
on n’y connaît rien dans un domaine
on peut en apprendre
juste ce qu’il nous faut.
Il s’agit là d’un des nombreux avantages
de concrétiser ses idées.
Concrétiser ses idées et ses projets
nous permet d’acquérir
des compétences et connaissances
que l’on n’aurait pas apprises
à l’école ou au travail, par exemple.
Et puis, ça peut nous mener
à des projets encore plus palpitants
et à faire des rencontres fabuleuses :
la preuve, je suis ici aujourd’hui.
Bref, les avantages prônent
largement sur les inconvénients.
Peut-être que certains d’entre vous,
ici dans la salle,
n’ont pas encore d’idées
ou de projets à réaliser en tête.
C'est le moment d'ouvrir
les yeux sur le monde.
Lorsqu’on prête attention
aux petits détails qui nous entourent,
il y a mille choses à améliorer.
Je vais vous raconter
l’histoire de Louis Braille.
Louis Braille est un petit garçon
énergique et curieux.
À l'âge de trois ans, il se blesse l'œil
avec un outil de l'atelier de son père.
C'est ainsi qu'il perd la vue.
Plus tard, dans son éducation,
il apprend à lire et à écrire
en passant ses mains
sur des caractères romains en relief.
Mais cette technique s’avère
peu efficace et gêne Louis Braille.
C’est ainsi qu’il va réfléchir
à un système mieux adapté à sa condition
et invente le braille en s’inspirant
du système de Barbier,
un officier à la retraite.
L’exemple de Louis Braille
est intéressant.
Il est parti d’une chose
qui ne lui convenait pas
pour inventer un système
qui lui faciliterait la vie.
Et d'ailleurs, il a facilité la vie
de beaucoup d'autres malvoyants.
On voit aussi, grâce à cet exemple,
qu’il n’est pas parti de zéro.
Il s'est inspiré du travail
d'une autre personne.
Donc on voit que si chacun apporte
son idée au monde, sa pierre à l’édifice,
on peut améliorer
non seulement sa propre vie,
mais la vie de plein d’autres personnes.
Pour ma part, le thème de l’écologie
m’inspirait énormément
et je ne savais pas encore
ce que j’allais présenter au concours.
Donc j’ai juste ouvert les yeux
sur ce qui m’entourait
et j’ai décidé de résoudre le problème
de gaspillage de la chaleur de l’eau,
un sujet parmi tant d’autres, à ma façon.
Je me suis dit que si personne
n’avait encore réagi à ce problème,
je n’allais pas me fermer cette porte
et ne pas y réfléchir
alors que je pouvais déjà le faire.
Je n’allais pas attendre que
quelqu’un d’autre le fasse à ma place.
Finalement, on a tous des bases
et des méthodes que l’on maîtrise.
Au départ, on a peur des obstacles,
mais ils ne sont qu’une question de temps,
et les avantages seront
de plus en plus nombreux.
C’est en observant ce qui nous entoure
que nous pourrons parvenir à résoudre
nos problèmes de tous les jours.
Chacun d’entre nous
peut être le changement.
Alors vous, qu’est-ce qui
vous titille au quotidien ?
(Applaudissements)